hey everyone here welcome back to yet
another installment of a hugely
staggering series and that isn't because
you know we don't want it to be it is
because Doomsday Clock is ridiculously
slow paced series and I would lie to you
dear listeners if I was saying I really
truly remember what happened and I think
that's partly a fault because it's quite
a boring insipid tale that we'll get to
which having this issue perfectly
amplifies but also because as I say
there are these weeks are these months I
think it has been about three months
since I last spoke to my co-host general
but deaf has a go sir yeah do really
well how's it going listeners thanks for
checking out the video much appreciate
it as always hope you enjoy the episode
I've got some right treats for you lined
up when we just completely rip
everything to shreds and we are debuting
this new thing now so if you're watching
this on YouTube which obviously you are
we'll try and follow along with the
comic as we do that's what we do pretty
much every episode but you know just if
you've got a hand definitely refer to it
and I said to you before we went on air
def like oh you know I'm not really
superhero guys discussed throughout the
show and whatever and you know I buy
comic books here and there I am actually
gonna buy the Doomsday Clock hardcover
not because I don't love it as this
great piece of fiction which it's not
but just just a [ __ ] like easily more
easily make sense of it like such a
fractured tale the here in issue 10
again just takes a complete right turn
in terms of pacing yeah it's a bit it
might be better once you digest it you
never know might be worse you might be
like probably way worse probably cause
the fault
now I remember what's happening I
remember how bad it is yeah but you know
this is gonna be one of those series
that perpetuates on I said you before
one of my fascinators at the moment he's
watching people I've joined on the bus
collections choi graphic novel
connection collections and they always
have the absolute editions and i'm sure
this will be collecting one of those you
know this is of course if you're not
aware and the quote-unquote official
Watchmen sequel but it was a butchering
of the source material and um and
let's just get into it the cover itself
Nathaniel dusk the series very own black
freighter tight narrative meta-narrative
did this inspire much confidence is
cover yeah it did actually like it's
very well drawn and it's got a sort of
noir feel to it I didn't totally forgot
about Nathaniel dusk and then yeah
picked it up look at this I was like oh
yeah Nathaniel dusk and so not probably
the best thing that opened chapter 10
with but I actually a bit of a spoiler
right now but actually probably prefer
this of the entire run it's probably
I've gotten my notes here it's my
favorite issue but I can't actually
remember anything that happened in it
cuz I read last week I've run a
listeners I've had a really sore throat
if you've been watching some of the
videos on the channel
I've been croaking through my 10 minute
videos so didn't really want to do a
full hour one which is why we're so late
yeah but yet their Cora member I read it
last week and I can remember what the
hell happened in it so it's gonna be
another great ever so guys IV yeah it's
like these issues are [ __ ] covered in
tachyons or whatever that thing that
blocks dr. manhattan's time vision on
like I just I can't recollect it you
know just recently I got future shocks
which you mention before the Alan Moore
sort of started on these 2018 many
things a collection of that so many of
those are really memorable tales that I
won't forget this I will the cover you
know we always feedback the covers on
watching and watching as well I mean
there are details on spotting I didn't
see before it's an awesome and Dyess of
inversion in the window
maybe for now maybe yeah it's quite a
nice little yeah it's like it's got a
weird shape to it isn't it the more
thing is Gary Franks oh it's brilliant
we always always lo it it's glow in that
window and I tell you I bet that's
pretty hard to do when you color and
stuff in I'm gonna say so I want to say
some horrific things about Geoff Johns
as we get through but I want to just
keep Gary Franks out of it I admire this
guy hugely
you know the image to me as if so much
of doomsday Clark it's a little bit on
the nose there's a little
too much narrative here that the
Watchmen covers kind of lack that you
pan out from we got a dame in the
doorway you know we know from the
coloring from the style it's Nathaniel
dusk who I most remember him as like old
old Mothman yeah in the nursing home I
think on earth I had visions on him and
stuff yeah um he was sort of sort of
been in the background of everything
really has knee and in the form of a TV
show and this sort of this issue opens
with telling the opposite side of that
TV show so you see the actors and you
sort of learn about the story of this
actor Carver Coleman and who was
betrayed
but he's every time we've seen him it's
just been like a little tiny tidbit so
he's had so little coverage that by the
tenth issue I'm not really that invested
in what could happen to him I know it's
significant somehow but beyond being
just a supporting character I don't
actually know how much he he really
means in the entire arc like the Black
Friday at this point there's been quite
a lot of coverage on it and so you know
you were more interested in in it
whereas this has just been always in the
background so do I care and I kind of
got the feeling when reading this that
he wouldn't be necessary anyway um and
yeah I don't care about this in the
story to be honest we had a massive
cliffhanger at the end of the last issue
and we've gotta wait again we've waited
three months or whatever for the next
issue and got away again and read
through this crap yes yeah it's like
when would be when Woody drives over you
know jumps over the canyon with bull's
eye it has that say well actually it's
nothing like that because it's absolute
codswallop it is just what I loved about
the black freighter stuff was it played
into the whole pirate idea in a
superhero war which is bringing that we
discovered on discussed an old episode
stuff like that but it was quite a
regional fictional form to explore the
kind of pirate you know penny paperback
but we've seen so many it's such a trope
think about home alone think about the
fade-out which I've said before Eddie
blue breaking Shaun Phillips one of my
all-time very graphic novels again
that's kind of like a new
or fake film in the wall reflects really
it's just a lazy crutch I think to fall
on that's easy to do this kind of
sneering runyan Eska dialog yeah
definitely and I've also been thinking
about I hope we don't get demonetised
for you saying codswallop tom we've got
me stressing out now but yet I don't
really care to be honest at this point
and it is really well written well
really well drawn so it's quite well the
dialogue is good yeah and it's as the
timeless feel to it but you know I don't
know why it's in like the comic and as
we discover Korver Coleman's backstory I
still still don't really know why so
from here we cut to dr. Manhattan after
we've seen Carver Coleman get betrayed
bloody hell I'm having to scroll through
and now Tom and I tell you what goes on
forever that Kaba Coleman shite yeah
it's there a lot I mean
yet the just quickly the nine grid
constrain I think is something that will
work for you if you're more s and could
really deliver on it but here it's a
little empty you know or we get hurt
picking up a box going down sultry and
it's just a little developing into the
main scene in the background but but
yeah we go through his life and I guess
you know this is the the purpose of him
is it I read this to a certain extent
that he his timeline was always the same
maybe like that you seem to be a because
this whole issue I mean to go to more of
a macro idea is exploring the kind of
mechanics of I mean personally death
what I hate you Bona comics I don't give
a [ __ ] about your alternate reality time
version tell the story so overdone right
now as well I need three acts we need
care development
yeah the alternate timeline thing it's
getting really over gone off the edge
you but he has gone crazy he's in it I
think yeah he likes roars himself like
now we've had Avengers endgame
everything is gonna go off into an
alternate timeline and it's just gonna
be everywhere a low end game but and
game was great not many people can
honestly honestly I think endgame will
probably win best picture really I can
see that happening I've seen that in
happening in like a kind of you know
return of the Gwang yeah black pant they
got nominated for Best Picture
I thought blacks as awful it's alright
it's not Best Picture material I don't
think no am I thinking that was kind of
the Oscars trying to beat down with a
kid because basically the Oscars is no
one's watching them anymore really no
one's watching a four-hour long Oscar
show especially when the next day you
can just open your phone look on
Facebook and you know all the winners
straight away so they need to pull in
the new audience and they were like
what's really popular it's Black Panther
I tell you what were nominating it for
Best Picture and obviously we wouldn't
end that year as well yeah it was it was
it was a given really but yeah doc
Manhattan approached a litter Ives as
you say kind of in a similar way to Mary
and mime that we've seen before you know
Bobby's seen him at the Gila flats base
as well I love this atom bomb entrance
yes yeah it's great and he just kind of
every time he shows up he kind of rocks
the landscape in the comic which is
great it's a nice entrance he kills a
policeman though doesn't he yeah and by
the looks of it
Carla Coleman just so happens to be
there and and you kind of scene hit him
sort of looking very sad on Mars he
doesn't know what time it is he sort of
got dementia in a way and and he's just
beaten the ban of superheroes that was
sent last time I obviously these guys so
you sort of you be in your Caelius
c-listers that you send to show that the
villains very powerful and but I really
think they should have sent like one of
the big three yeah like between Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman to demonstrate
this like obviously Superman couldn't
because he's now tied to deeply in a
punching dr. Manhattan ban is far too
weak to punch be damaged yeah yeah in
the forest or pew in blast yeah I think
Wonder Woman right
right now she's arguably DC's most
popular character if you were just to
ask the general public I think we should
have sent her to show that he's being
feared because again it's a trope
- you know you kill off one of the minor
characters at the start to kind of show
that the guys really powerful and stuff
and you're like whoa how Superman gonna
do it but yeah not there is yeah I mean
there is a playfulness with John's
depiction of Manhattan I appreciate I
wonder if that is why I was drawn here
he asks as well you know in the panel I
see myself on Mars or is that now time
is it
I love the you know you see this in
every comic book ever the heart
superheroes stance where they're like
comedies or in this case kind of a
conscious with their arms up like yeah
very good kind of out of our stomach
it's also paid lip-service to hear that
this is part of the multiverse and thus
we know for definite now that dr.
Manhattan didn't create the DC Universe
he journeyed to it but he didn't create
it so there's been lots of fan theories
that in the new 52 and dr. Manhattan
sort of created the the DC Universe but
we know for definite tommnow so tell
tell the people in the comments to shut
up I'm sick of reading the stupid
comments a lot of the comic death as we
push on is Manhattan and the actor you
know I've already forgot his name I'm
not gonna go back and read is see see
see see I mean naturally you know he's
below the main message and he's a bit
anonymous but but as I said he's got an
alliteration and his name though like
all good comic book characters do yeah
yeah exactly and you know it's quite
nice actually I do like the aspect to it
where it's like okay yeah if you met
Manhattan he could legit say oh yeah
he'll die this day you'll marry this
person you'll stop your toe in this
microseconds like and he speaks to
someone and reveals what the fate is or
does he conjure the fate as well or
maybe no no yeah it's kind of fate
versus free will this is you I feel um
and one thing I picked up which I
thought I was dead clever for not was in
but it actually happens in the issue was
that he arrived in 1938 which comic book
wise is really close to the creation of
Superman
which kind of plays in at the end but
when I was reading this I was like yes
I'm so smart
yeah but they also have Verna Brothers
and that's sort of a tiny Warner
Brothers who obviously own DC at this
point and I'm running it into the ground
depending on how you look at it and they
got this diner way too revealed that dr.
Manhattan can't look into the future and
something he's saying he can't look into
the future basically but I never took it
as him being able to look into the
future
I always just thought he was solved all
time for him was happening at once and
due to his tachyon due to his connection
to the tachyons he could see time
cyclically instead of just in a straight
line but no apparently Tom he's a
fortune teller yeah yeah he just it's
quite nicely has to focus on one thing
perhaps but the explanation for the you
know dearth of his powers isn't really
scoped on to and the whole sequence with
the backing of the chairs I know it
wants to be cute but it's kind of
redundant I did quite like the rise and
fall of comma Coleman sure I mean a
little played out though right
oh you burn and especially when there's
that bit way sitting alone yeah she's
sitting alone what happened
and but you sort of getting a feeling
that because he tells and Daniel dusk
yeah sorry Carver Coleman see see I tell
them that he's gonna die and that sort
of sends them off the deep end and again
it's you know this fate versus choice
thing that's always been a nice debate
in the Watchmen series and so yeah nice
little scene that got me interested in
Karla Coleman at this point leaving the
photo behind though come on yeah doc
don't do wrong with you
but then Tom Boonen storytelling cut to
the green car home what comics like
wiping yourself off like wow we don't
need you to mythologize Superman in a
cornfield again like it's definitely
used to monetize now Tom it's
it's so self-serving like it's just ah I
don't know it's just it's it's so done
I've seen this before
yeah comics are so self referential they
love themselves but in a little bit
anything they can do I want one of them
right I want our DC comic one day a
reference the Marvel Universe I've loved
that that would be late xi they they
have met quite a few times yeah yeah
they're an amalgam series actually Tom
funny story when I used to be in high
school they actually had loads of
amalgam graphic novels in the school
library so me my friends one day where
we knew they were worth a bit a pop when
in one a word stood with a backpack on
reading a book who's not looking
suspicious in the other one just took
the amalgam books off the the library
shelf put them in the backpack zipped it
up and walked out so I've got about five
of them you'll never you'll never catch
me copper but they've gone to a better
place Tom they weren't getting read in
that library that's how I'd tell myself
this thing about night and so yeah you
get the famous car from Action Comics
which is obviously their issue that day
be Superman debuted in yeah very famous
cover of him lifting a green car Bionic
smashing it into a rock as robbers run
right and because of this this didn't
happen in the current DC timeline you
get mention that the DC Universe is
splitting into alternate timelines from
this point we'll also get the origins as
told by dr. Manhattan up like yes Silver
Age superheroes such as Alan Scott Jay
Garrick dr. fate and you know what I
like comics yeah so I did enjoy this I
know the wank and each other off or
whatever you said but I liked it so shut
the hell up I'm too much of a more fan
of I've read too much of the black
dossier by leave extraordinaire
gentlemen like where he parodies
superior origins like this stuff is too
earnest personally and I've always felt
DC's hero's pale aesthetically to Marvel
like I don't give a [ __ ] about Hawkman
I've always felt badly
designed em yeah to pet I do probably
prefer the DC heroes just because I've
lined them sort of more iconic and
Marvel are really popular at the moment
just because of how relatable that the
heroes are whereas DC heroes you caught
you can't relate to a multi-billionaire
you know I mean whose lives in a mansion
with a butler and but you know your
local friendly neighborhood spider-man
he's just swinging about the streets
trying to do good I can relate to that a
bit I pick I picked up some litter the
other day Tom and put it in the bin so
you know I mean we're all doing my part
can't relate to what Batman does but I
probably prefer you know Batman's be
favorite probably Iron Man's a close
second well now you know shadow demon in
the ball basically Iron Man in the MCU
is everything that I wanted Batman to be
in the DC Universe the movies yeah loads
of loads of gadgets loud to telling
people to [ __ ] off you say yeah [ __ ]
yourself there's no kids listener who
this show is there Tom it's unlikely
it's unlikely by now I mean I don't want
to wait too far into these wars because
I don't really know what to talk about
but the changed yeah the fabric of the
DC Multiverse
is being redefined yeah from what I
gather again don't not really ok with
these stories but crisis flashpoint zero
hour you know a lot of things are kind
of a bit like blackest night that I know
is a big John's arc that you talk about
a lot of stuff together to like this is
quite ambitious on that front yeah it's
sort of saying that basically because DC
loved resetting the clock all the time
and obviously you can get really
invested in stories and then for some
new hot young writer to come along and
be like that story didn't happen your
[ __ ] doing a new one
good stuff sucks hey listen to me no
denying people there's so many reboots I
mean there was the the new 52 and then
rebirth a couple years later and this is
just kind of saying look guys all your
favorite stuff
did happen so there is a reason to go
back and buy all those old books because
there with reading um and you you get
the the the Minutemen photograph as well
kind of a play on that which are quite
like yeah that was nice yep there you
got a Kent farm origins is Superman yeah
yeah that's a million times death of
Superman's parents yeah but also some of
them are alive in another timeline and
they all kind of pivot around this one
person which is Superman everyone's
favorite hero four years ago
she's not popular anymore but DC haven't
realized and do quite like Superman and
I love ya great depend on who's right
now he's great he can be a great
character definitely but here he's kind
of like all-american winning isn't he
like he's the beating heart of the
universe it seems to me a verse yeah
definitely he's you know he's that
basically started superheroes off so I
can't deny it Superman is the most
important comic book character of all
time because without him you don't get
you don't get polka dot man you don't
get crazy quilt you don't you definitely
don't get zebra man so you need you need
Superman around to make sure that those
heroes are invented and and I know you
were hating that map I put in my notes
here it masterfully I think retells the
history of Superman and all his
different reincarnations and rebirths
over the air over the airs and how he
will forever be a symbol of hope and
even the one now will soon be outdated
and part of a legacy that works in a
cycle so it's coming back to this notion
that time cyclical everything's
repeating but dr. Manhattan he can't
handle it Tom he's really annoyed at it
so he starts altering the DC Universe
which we discover is the matter verse
and this is why then the new 52 creation
was attributed to him and also rebirth
however the universe bite
back in the form of Wally West he was
very notably missing from the new 52 run
before he became back in rebirth to
basically warn everyone um so yeah dr.
Manhattan he created the Metaverse Tom
what you think about that what you think
about Doc kind just go into these comics
and just [ __ ] around no no not what I
love is he doesn't read know what he's
doing it's like say you know I keep
mentioning I'm a web web designer by
trade um sometimes I have to go in his
stuff in an indica coding stuff I've got
no idea what I'm doing I'm just randomly
[ __ ] around and hoping that it works
out dr. Manhattan he loves it but he's
gonna get punched in the face for it Tom
which is also what happens at my work
there you know sometimes people think in
scripts of answers to questions you've
had for a long time I guess especially
in comics and they have a certain
perspective on it that I do think
delightful do think is to life or I have
to agree
the Manhattan viewing every reality and
every reality being a reboot of DC so
good sick of all these reboots Tom isn't
here yet yeah this is easier he sees
like crap Morris Dees he's Tom King like
yeah he's just sick of it everyone's
sick of reboots italia tom jun right
it's been the worst month for movies in
a long time godzilla bombed em men and
black bombed what else toy story's not
doing that well it's doing all right but
it's not doing as well as expected
Chucky's bombing right now Dark Phoenix
x-men he's sick of it Tom we're all sick
of it and he's just like I'm sick of
this [ __ ] I'm changing it but in doing
it he's ruining it as well.you sake fan
out cry and it is building up it is
funneling towards at its bottom super
and versus dr. Manhattan and we get some
straight-up
they're like labeling each other just
sees them and runs over to punch oh yeah
and that's it that's the entire thing
there's no reason why these two
characters dislike each other I'm sorry
but there's no reason for it other than
dr. Manhattan's Beaton there's c-listers
who is Superman's mate you know I mean
like there's no real reason for any of
this fight to happen at this point
this is Batman V Superman all over again
there's no motivation for it there's no
real reason for them to fight
they're just having it out cuz comic
fans whoo we can we got to see a fight
that's what they like Tom they're
scumbags I tell you that for free for
other still oh they better not still be
listening at this primary for you man if
they've heard we just call them all
scumbags I'm really dad that's my
channel over if that's the case I'd like
more would sometimes do symmetry in
paneling so brilliantly like in the
black freighter etc but here we pretty
much have a like-for-like as we segue
back into Nathaniel dusk you know Carla
Coleman land which again I'm not
interested in I'm not really interested
in this multiverse war either but
there's no momentum is there there's no
real forward movement in actually the
story yeah I mean basically karma dies
he's killed by his mother and her
associate like John knew this but he
doesn't step in and again it kind of
yeah he's sort of never a tile removed
years and how he doesn't really care and
he's not really willing to help anyone
he sort of does nothing he's an observer
he is the villain because he's a
pacifist and yeah he's always just been
up in action though and yeah so don't
really know why this makes the character
interesting it was like you hero and
your villain this should be basically
poke well I suppose they are kind of
polar opposites Superman's a man of
action from Action Comics number one
and dr. Manhattan's a pacifist I don't
care anymore
just get it over with John's can they
satisfyingly wrap up so many loose ends
like we're thinking of like Rorschach
junior thinking of my memory now Ozzy so
many characters maybe that's why they've
left it so long because I just hope that
people will forget and just remember it
as being about Superman where's dr.
Manhattan yeah that's what I would do
post a post really bad stuff on my
channel all the time and I just hope
people forget yeah
they [ __ ] it and like a character with
their eyes closed opening them ending
anything is so done so many episodes of
so many shows everything it's always the
cliffhanger like what they woke up it's
always there in bed as well didn't
Superman have a dream of dr. Manhattan
in the first issue
yeah and that's how that issue ended
yeah yeah and I tell you what Tom I
watch a lot of TV for my youtube channel
and the amount of cliffhanger that
cliffhanger is that or basically someone
in bed waking up corner yeah it's not
good last one I remember watching Oh
every watched Game of Thrones from
season 1 and after bran gets pushed out
of the window oh yes how one of the
episodes picks up with bran waking up so
what is he gonna tell everyone about
Jaime Lannister and Cersei and again
it's a bit [ __ ] here but I've gotten my
notes it's a nice take and retread of
the DC Universe my favorite from the run
it's a smart way to take the universe
and it's great that John's actually
managed to make sense of all the reboots
and have them as one coherent thing
which I suppose we've got to give him
credit for anything about it I guess so
I mean it's just the fact that he has
the goal to try and tie all the issues
like more did we've established that
more would come up with these long
quotes that were part of bigger quotes
reflected what the quote and the issue
was and yes great tie-in I think of the
judge of all the earth which is the
further the abyss gazes also abroad to
Ryder's wish it was an old classic and
look at my work see my to read which is
from Oz even Dyess the poem by Shelley
which is about the cat you know oh
that's pretty
this one's called action this one's
literally called one word that you can
take any quote frog like okay reflects
the fact that the [ __ ] directors
they're the Fritz Lang type figure it's
actually a Socrates quote every action
has its pleasures and its price oh my
god again what is that really saying
like that doesn't have any inference
yeah definitely
and I'm ditch yeah it's again it's just
there's nothing enlightening about that
quote no it's just googled it's
basically just googled action yeah -
it's got a wiki quote and he's Google
yeah say he's not doing a good job is he
gonna slag the light off he's not doing
a good job
well obviously let us know you know what
you think of this issue a lot of people
have been really positive in the reactor
I'm looking at the I'm looking on comic
book roundup now which is basically
Metacritic our best website ever max 9.1
critic rating and honestly some of the
everyone's given it tends by the looks
of it there's one will do what we
normally do will steal someone else's
content and that pass it offers were
owned so even the lowest score is a
seven out of ten hair from Batman news
who says a slow burner the beginning
turns into a roll clicking celebration
of Superman
John's pacing in the first half of the
issue is probably the weakest it's been
the whole series there were a lot of
attention paid to a person who works
better as a plot device and as an actual
character what's things get going though
it turns into a fascinating Mel
meditation on Superman's influence in
the real world and on the printed page
yeah I think that's fair enough
what's with ten's though they're the
best ones to read yep yep comic
Crusaders Johnny the Machine Hughes this
issue has gone a long way in giving some
credibility to the storytelling of this
run with John's essentially giving
reasons for all the reboots and crisis's
them there may be bigger implications
yet to come don't know what that means
with issue 11 June July well that's not
coming out is it the final issue should
be out by September by which point we
will be in the midst of a Leviathan and
the air of the villain with that in mind
I am curious to see what ramifications
if any the Doomsday Clock will have on
the DC Universe how does that get 10 out
of 10 yeah the guys saying I don't know
what's happening some other stuff out
this yeah sure yeah every time I upload
one of these videos it kills the
analytics so much right right so so yeah
guys let us know what you think of the
issue obviously we weren't as warm to it
as some of the other critics out yeah
just again not too much to say about the
[ __ ] issue man like you know it's
just nothing really stands out to me
yeah Chuck's still listening it sucks
yep yep well you know subscribe to deaf
Channel obviously go check out all our
old Watchmen episodes that we did and we
interviewed [ __ ] John Higgins the
original colorist what with with yeah
definitely
yeah I'm just reading the supplementary
material here oh yeah I saw through that
yeah there's a script which basically
dusk recounts that his wife had died and
he's in his Detective Agency on
Christmas Eve and someone comes in with
verbs I'm sort of brass or something
it's quite anodyne staff also a blood
splatter
about his wife being killed and I think
his children were taken away or
something but I mean just what you don't
want an issue that has progressed like
molasses [ __ ] the Fanueil dusk [ __ ]
yeah it's not worth checking out is it
do you think you could skip this issue
completely oh yeah you could yeah yeah
there's no moves made by any characters
so yeah cuz it's like you you sort of
end with the last issue with the heroes
being defeated this issue don't really
go anywhere does it no nowhere this this
this could have been like the third
issue yeah definitely doesn't go
anywhere sucks
like comment subscribe so uh so yeah
guys we'll be back to do the next issue
whenever that is but deaf it's always a
pleasure bro it's lovely and thanks
everyone for still listening thanks guys
alright man that was yeah oh we're still
going it's a good night for me and it's
a good night friend Qui